je vous avais demandé un petit peu à
tous ici de préparer une chanson de noël
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez mais
oui il enregistrait maria k reen
s'entraîne oui allez vous aviez un coach
vocal mais rien n'était sûr on était si
vous voulez jamais dire si vous nous
rejoignez ça fait plusieurs étés c'était
il ya trois semaines je réponds
enregistré une chanson et il a un coach
vocal un petit peu particulier qui avait
une odeur dans la bouche sur la tête de
ma mère
il voulait absolument alors par les
prêts et savez vous saviez pas que c'est
une caméra cachée
non mais non c'était de me renseigner à
rien et tout le monde m'a juré commun et
bien regardez il y en a un qui est grave
vénère je vous dis ça a failli ce peta
c'est benjamin castaldi
regardez c'est là une première au nom
bonjour on sait enfin tu es je vais je
vais te coûter un peu ouais bah oui mais
tu étais intéressé sur une grosse merde
donc tu sais que sa part du ventre
d'accord je te demander de mettre la
main sur son ventre
donc tu inspires
[Musique]
je le sens bien
tu vois que cela
[Musique]
ce cas qu'est ce qu'il méritait a fait
rater à faire à des affaires des foot et
au corps oui mais ça c'est une émotion
que le tueur
ça me fait refuser ces trucs là de quoi
ça veut dire flows et ces trucs là ça
joue sur un terrain faisait péter péter
les accords mets tout mon staff on a
gâché les allées mais mais je pense que
tu es assez alarmant pardon c'est
peut-être moi qui te ma présence qui te
dérange mais non pas du tout mais
c'était impressionner ou quoi ou je ne
sais pas ce que tu as vu donc large
s'est pas vu à la télé vraiment
désagréable le bon coaching vocal chez
bon ok on fait un petit vocalises sur
coucou faire sien où et avec 1 h aspiré
coucou vous
[Musique]
songeons
oh
je veux sentir ton air qui vient vers
mon visage tu sembles bien oui beaucoup
[Musique]
un petit exercice de diction vite fait
d'accord tout simplement je me suis dit
nous ne tenterons tiendront pas monotone
nous ne tentons à damas nous ne nous
faisons nôtre montre vous fasse moi
qu'ils allaient nous ne nous
désolidarisons pas toujours évident mais
c'est facile normalement mais nous ne
nous déçoit l'aide des roses remplie
parkway vas-y encore une ou deux nous
donnons des salaires devront soit pas ok
je sais moi j'entends dans les ca sont
roquette a causé qui avant comme un star
zaz par exemple d'amstar tu exagères non
n'ose imaginer internationale ça ok ok
france et gilles verdez le prochain
c'est gilles verdez que gilles verdez m
l'anchois avec un peu de choix un peu
d'oignons bien cru bonjour j marc fait
prêt à coopérer
vraiment donc je mets juste la main sur
la tiennent pour vérifier que tu prends
bien leur part le monde d'accord allez
on reprend d'accord ferme et inspiré
ça va aller ça va ça va certains très
sensible aux odeurs tout ça ouais quand
je suis rentré dans le studio annonce
est vrai que j'ai senti une odeur
toi aussi tu fais quoi moi sans merci
donc on va faire 1 h aspiré devant le au
cou on peut pas boire un petit café ou
n'ont qu'à pas envie d'un café ou un
truc non ce que vous n'y a pas une salle
de bain on voit ça comme ça one on ne
peut pas se laver les dents ou un truc
comme ça non non j'ai l'impression que
tu as envie de me dire quelque chose
mais que tu n'oses pas mais ils parlent
parlent librement
bah en fait tu pue de la gueule c'est
vrai à plusieurs est-ce que vous allez
en tout cas voudront pas sonné
conditions mais c'est pas comme ça
franchement j'attends mais six mois
après on fait un truc comme ça
c'est bizarre moi je préfère puis de la
gueule c'est à dire que personne soigner
sa maladie
je n'ai pas perdu ma demande un truc et
je suis pas très bien du tout du tout et
c'est ce qui nous rend mon temps ce
resto be missed steurs faut arrêter de
me démangeait démodé chose qui pue parce
que franchement votre haleine là ça me
dérange
tout à l'heure j'ai rien dit mais vous
avez fait quoi bouffer de la youth et
une caméra cachée
mais vous me soufflait encore dans la
bouche comme ça je vous jure vous êtes
repartir d'où vous venez alors
des tests live donc vous sortez de la
pièce parce que vous plus de la gueule
merci beaucoup merci
et vite ça va je m'énerve
[Musique]
voilà
alors j'ai pas dû s que l'odeur et
écoles insupportable woods avait
vraiment vous voyez vous fait mal au
locker direct away pur infernale comme
hadders et n'étiez pas bien du tout
avoir non mais c'est insupportable le
gars est bon mais si tu perds mon latin
julien on peut l'applaudir julienc et
viable il habite
[Applaudissements]